[Music]
how's it going reject nation Greg Alva
here John we are going to watch another
episode of Cobra Kai episode 5 counter
balance supposedly this is the best
episode according to a lot of people's
feedback on the show so far before we do
that it's the end of the month so I want
to say thank you to everyone who's been
joining our patreon page thus far with
your q and A's music video coverage and
we do a TV show watch along for many a
show on my personal line I cover attack
on Titan Gotham almost done with a
season for the flash Jon's end he has
finished off Riverdale season 1 he's on
season 2 right now he's caught up to
Atlanta they start a Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood together we cover
my hero academia just finished all
season 1 almost done with season 2 of
Jessica Jones one more episode left the
Black Lightning and of course Cobra and
with that in mind patron the day shout
out for Eric Oliver Eric my man Madhu my
homie my bro the Mandan with the fandom
Mandan with the fandom you're always so
busy that you rarely get back to me on
time get you're one of our highest
pledges I find it funny how you're one
of our highest ones and yet you seem
like you don't care for any of the
reward tiers anymore am i cool with that
oh yeah but does it make me feel guilty
oh yeah totally totally no I feel so
guilty
what I feel is love for you we live in
California you should come visit us
sometime it's much nicer at our
two-bedroom apartment than it is your
your three-bedroom house let's watch
this hit him play excited
building yoga
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yo guys no preparation just go down get
in the position kill Johnny Lawrence
then I was a human being to my friend
characters oh yeah oh he's playing this
lever I am going out you know it is 9le
week so really pointed us spending time
again I appreciate you coming in but
there are no girls in Kovac I'll what
bro same reason there are women in the
army what rock is even yeah so you seen
its genetic or love for Twinkies comes
today and she's a paying customer what a
dick
you know all emotional loud complaining
never letting you finish the sentence
[Music]
tell me things like ugly you start a
YouTube channel
it's like how you make it yeah speaks to
me smoke and dank marijuana drugs like
burst his stomach open goes the natural
Cobra
[Music]
okay I get why he wants to go that's
disturbing
okay you just get more customers deep
that heart just fight the landlord do
they work right across the street from
McDonald's karate dude you're telling me
that the holes are carrying dinner was
just some convoluted plot so you could
raise the rent on your child
spray painted a dick on my face he's an
[ __ ]
the longer you into one o lessons or the
dark midpoint hair I hate her so much
Oh what why would she turn on her
fight fight oh yeah you know that move
dog oh yeah yeah killing the game you
get a little Jackie Chan yeah they're
using props
hi-oh about using your environment dude
boom that's a signal well earn moment
like so many high school Wallflower sit
okay go back to Taiwan this big dumb one
when I school call me Yaya answered you
ever seen her so proud oh let me get
this straight
you took all the lessons I taught you
and you use them just straight-up beat
the [ __ ] out follow me I could not have
been more proud if you were my real son
I was gonna give him an official key
sure
only until I repair my relationship with
myself
no mr. Miyagi
it is where is this local cemetery your
daughter's about to have sex with the
lead student of Cobra Kai that's very
nice
you gotta kick John lowers his ass Wow
[Laughter]
like a super soldier I don't know one
kid now he's got all these students
you're gonna just state it like a boss
yeah I didn't talk with anyone are these
kids just [ __ ] yeah YouTube video
keep it looks like one business dude
he's got to make Miguel a partner
so what's he doing he's building a dojo
within his home
yeah lever girl and Danny's gonna train
yeah for no reason
[Music]
hey Sean right there
you've really made a nice room yeah yeah
all dates
[Music]
that's right 2005 2005 nope not stopping
it not gonna widen again no more
spoilers yeah I actually have to jet to
go to another collab so I can't really
talk for too long about this I would say
this is one of the best I mean I've only
seen five episodes but this did have
arguably the most rewarding moment out
of the entire cent emphasis so far like
it's a good it's a good episode five to
have that happen at because they've been
building so much up to that moment where
Kyler's being a douche bag all the time
Danny larusso's daughter like you know
father then we you know she she should
probably be leaning towards Miguel
Miguel keeps Kenny his ass kicked but I
liked is that he didn't like take one
lesson took a little time yeah in a
training montage yeah he got to actually
train for a while to where it built up
in the locker room he gets his ass
handed to him after he's trained for
awhile where he got enough skills now
he's got enough skills where he could
hand collars ass to him by doing it in
front of a crowd of people at school
that's like a dream cenar just the right
moment and i'll build to the right
moment you know like they built it up
very well with all the high school teen
drama with Samantha kind of leaning away
from that clique that she was with and
and not knowing who Kyler really is and
she's getting humiliated at school and
then he gets to have his chance of
redemption Miguel I thought that was
really well written and it's ultimately
redeeming for Johnny Lawrence as well
because it allows the school to boom off
of a natural event where he put a lot of
quality training and did yet he did
right and Johnny Lawrence's also earned
this as well
yeah totally and I like the way that
they're allowing the characters to be
sort of gray like at the top of the
episode Johnny's basically like I want a
girl in my class girls aren't supposed
to fight same reason there aren't women
in the oil in the new moons they don't
completely flip his character around but
you get that he's at least starting the
journey of maybe being a better human
being I got Danny on the opposite side
who like we know and love but who is
doing some pretty despicable things in
this episode and having a come back to
Center and even her friend shuns her for
being a [ __ ] yeah yeah and I appreciate
that they're allowing those kinds of
little gray area character notes to take
place here basically and for Danny
Larusso too I like how this show allows
them to Teeter
on to jerk territory quite a bit
actually there are times where this show
will really flip who's the antagonist in
this episode in this dynamic they're
both learning to be human I do the
shadows of the path they're both very
gray qualities well I like they draw
them both you know Danny and Johnny has
two dudes they don't know each other
that well but they really don't like
each other yeah and that's kind of a
fascinating place to come from and it's
a lot more interesting than I thought a
show like this would go for you know
because you do get to see them both as
protagonists and antagonists man and
this is kind of the natural order of
things and you're free to agree
sometimes in disagree other times the
Robie storyline like really unrealistic
annoying vibes about that kid unless
unless he turns out to be a serial
killer then I'll be like ah I get it
yeah I see where there we go now yeah
it's kind of like creepy kid vibes I'm
50/50 on that story cuz like when he's
at home with his mom and they actually
did a little character development you
can see like the first Inklings of ha
you know maybe I should give dad a shot
I like the idea there but certain things
in other parts the episode like where he
comes across them hugging it like the
exact right moment and you know that
he's gonna probably be pretty upset
about that I can see the thing where
he's working at the Larusso dealership
being maybe interesting or fun in some
way but what I'm really dreading is them
drawing this out yeah I felt like they
could have canned that storyline with
Robbie just focus on like the the fact
is he can't make repairs with his kid he
refuses to and that's the kids decision
but now he gets to form this
relationship with Miguel and I kind of
like that focus there's a your time with
yeah him back there wasn't cool yeah I
feel like later on you could reintroduce
him bring him back bring the storyline
after everything here is fully complete
or fleshed out but they kind of have
this like sinister twist ending of I'm
gonna be working for Danny Larusso now
at first I was like oh that's messed up
and then when I think about it and like
what's what's gonna do today Daniel
Russo's car plates with and even my
this is gonna be kind of what's gonna be
trained on you know unless Daniel
Larusso goes on a path of you know
training people again he's just set up a
whole dojo yeah that's what I'm really
wondering or if maybe cuz this episodes
also about Danny coming back to a place
of balance I thought that moment where
he goes and visits mr. Miyagi's grave
was really nice and it brought him back
down to a damn level so maybe this is
gonna be a tool to have Danny open him
up to the idea of going back to his dad
in some weird way like I see that maybe
happening it sucks like mr. Miyagi can't
be around anymore due to his passing
it's cool that this show really does
hone in on the spirit of him still like
you do feel the spirit of the mr. Miyagi
character in that scene when he's
talking to the to the tombstone
yes I am hey this was a great episode
this is a fantastic episode really all
about balance called counterbalances
episodes all right guys well thanks for
watching you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bow full-length TV show reactions over
at our patreon would love to have you
become a patron jek today